you know what uh i watched in the cinema
what the batman oh how was it very very
good really have you watched it yeah no
no is it three hours yes okay and i
loved it how was rob wood pattinson in
there delightful just a tree yeah what a
great guy what a great guy what a what a
what a bloke
okay i saw him the other day it was like
it was like 2010 it was like women like
fawning over rob pattinson yeah like 20
20 men fawning over roller patterns yeah
it's so true dude hell yeah it's good
it's a good movie that's a good movie is
it a good movie or is it a good batman
movie
ah
i think it's not that much for a batman
movie really it's because i i'd give it
an 8.5
because i'm like i'm like one of i'm
like one of the weird people who really
don't give that much of a [ __ ] about
batman i don't know to me to me it's
just i really like this portrayal by by
rob plattson yeah i thought is it like
more like
is it kind of more like on like the like
joker side
of like storytelling or is it more like
a batman begins oh oh well
if that's the scale that we're going
with i guess it would lean more towards
the joker's side okay uh but i wouldn't
i wouldn't compare it to the joker
either it's more like
they clearly want to tell
batman
as a character through this kind of
somewhat realistic lens of like if
batman was a real person yeah he would
be a [ __ ] weirdo like more like a
human drama side of things well it's
yeah it's a kind of detective movie but
also you know they don't shy away from
showing batman as being
having a lot of issues yeah yeah but the
man's got problems yeah yeah you know
and um more money more problems yeah
dude and uh i liked the villain i
thought it was pretty good the riddler
this time the real thriller oh [ __ ] i
thought they did a good really a really
interesting take on the riddler that i
liked um
i just had fun like i was i was there
for three hours maybe towards the end i
felt like i could have hurried up a
little bit yeah but overall i wasn't
bored i really enjoyed it i had a great
time i'm interested to see what riddler
is like in a movie of that caliber right
because to me the riddler is jim carrey
it's literally the opposite it is
opposite okay
yeah i think you i think you'd both like
it if you watched it i'm sure i would
yeah and uh it's like a cinema
experience okay it was [ __ ]
the thing that's always wondered me
about the riddler is how the [ __ ] would
that work in the age of google you know
like the rhythm comes up with like a
riddle or something and batman's like
hold on a second okay i got the answer
now i got the answer i better i think i
saw that in the buzzfeed
it's like the one youtube short that he
like watched the other day and he's just
like i remember that one i know the
answer to that one [ __ ] i would i would
look and i would show you on tick tock
but it's the algorithm's so [ __ ]
the only issue with my with the movie is
that i wish robert pattinson was just
out of the costume more he's just so
good does he does he do like the gravely
like man like oh yeah he does yeah okay
he's pretty good at it okay he's just
really good at doing voices in general
actually he's just a good actor he's a
good actor right definitely i watched i
watched good time again after i was like
you gotta watch good time it's so good
please watch good time it's so good
cause i can't think of has there ever
been a batman that i thought was
interesting because before the okay i
feel like before the dark knight rises
batman just had a like had like an awful
streak of just bad movies and that just
made his dc in general yeah
you don't like the george clooney batman
well with the [ __ ] back credit card
and the [ __ ] bat nipples
[ __ ]
even the best thing about that was
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger as uh mr
freeze nice to meet you nice to meet you
yeah i i just feel like for the longest
time batman was just either a boring or
comical character to me and the most
interesting characters were the villains
of batman and yeah yeah the only time i
thought batman was an interesting
character was actually during the
animated series
um like that was like that was that was
peak batman for me yeah yeah definitely
have you have you seen the animator
series yeah i love the animation how
does this compare to like the animated
series because that to me that that is
good that man it's a different
experience though entirely i feel like
it's hard to compare them both when
they're both trying to do wildly
different things right
i think
um but that's also so good because mark
hamill's the joker in that is amazing
yeah
just this is just connor talking about
media in general
kind of sell me on it
just watch it no there's a lot of stuff
i'll tell you not to watch i don't think
it's worth your time this however is
worth your time did you play the batman
arkham games as well i loved the batman
arkham asylum game dude i got a story
based game that was played well it's
hardly story the combat was fun and
punching and exploring stuff that's true
i don't know what the story was i know
joker it was
[Music]
[Laughter]
god damn it i thought we had one thing
in goblin for once when he's got goopy
gamer brain yeah i liked it and there
was also the combat trials that [ __ ] was
fun as [ __ ] you did the combat trials
because i was like i was like a i was
addicted to getting all the achievements
[ __ ]
those side stories well no so so i i was
obsessed with gamer score
that's the like that's like the last
thing i do like if
i hate it when there is like a [ __ ]
when there's a point in the game where
you can like do a trial for the combat
or one of the game mechanics i'm like
get this [ __ ] out my face i don't know
me too me too yeah okay unless there's
achievements
okay so you're an achievement hannah
i was i wasn't ashamed so here's what
happened right um when i first got my
xbox and i discovered these achievement
things i thought oh that's pretty that's
pretty cool that's a pretty cool thing
to strive towards and then my friend was
an achievement hunter
and i i was like i want to be better
than him at this
and so i was like well i'm just i'm
going to start doing it and then you're
kind of addicted to it and i would like
i would research games that were easy to
get all of the achievements on yeah and
then buy them and and do them just to
get the achievement score yeah i had
like
60 000 gamer score or something you
could only get about a thousand a game
normally yeah so so i had but you got
dlc for some stuff as well
i i bought lost the game
like this tv show lost specifically
because you could get all the
achievements in like two hours
really yeah i don't know what happened
i was absolutely addicted to getting
these achievements and arkham asylum was
one of them i got 100 on and it's really
hard because you had to do one of the
trials and maintain a combo of like a
hundred or something i can't remember
what it was
a lot of people also
and there was also like you had to do
all the stealth missions perfectly as
well yeah or something like that i can't
remember exactly i remember it was
really hard getting all the achievements
but that was such a good game i didn't
mind doing it mm-hmm when's the last
time you did that then or even achieving
collectors yeah yeah since i was like oh
1890 when i went to university and i had
less time kind of realized that like
wasn't that fun
it's not fun
it's not fun i have i had gotten one of
the hardest achievements uh on xbox
right which is like um
staying alive on um dead rising oh for
seven days straight yeah yeah you did
that no not that one it was another dead
rising one not the seven day one what
makes it so hard wait that's on the
first game right that's dead rising one
yes i've done all of them on dead rising
too oh [ __ ] which is i think no they
have like kill one million zombies or
something stupid right right sorry
another three days one my mom would have
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you had to be
the that one was you had to be alive in
like hardcore dead rising endless for
seven real days like in the real world
how did you get that what was the other
thing you'd have to go and shift surely
yeah yeah what was the one i did on all
of them on dead rising 2 are really hard
i know that took so long
and that's just like a difficult game
yeah there's some games that you know
this i oh
maybe this is why i hate jrpgs jrpgs
always had the hardest achievements yep
the most and they had the most cruelest
ones where like get this item that if
you miss it you can't go back and get it
[ __ ] you so that's i think that that
that is what genuinely stopped me from
ever buying a
like people have to jrpg psychopaths
like you do
rpgs you do whereas i'm looking at you
joe what do you think how many times did
you have to like play persona 5 before
you 100 percent like six times yeah
exactly but i also 100 at uh final
fantasy 7 remake as well oh my god well
that one's not too bad i guess that's
not too bad yeah because i i feel like
that's like a third of like the original
game yeah exactly exactly i wouldn't
dare do it with the original oh no no no
[ __ ] that like i feel like they've
become a lot more accommodating in these
modern times compared to like ogj rpg
games where they assume that that's the
only game you're playing for the entire
year yeah they just assume that's the
only game you have on that console yeah
i'm just gonna last you the entire exact
time i'm trying to find my xbox profile
so i can see what i've done i think it's
this one isn't the hardest uh xbox
achievement the [ __ ] mega man 9 one
what's that what's that one it's the one
where you have to beat the entire game
without getting hit a single time
which is oh so that's just a no-hit run
but an actual achievement yeah which if
you've played any mega man game is
practical no um what's the game uh one
of the tom clancy games had an
achievement for being the number one
ranked player in the world oh yeah yeah
yeah no joke
i remember i remember i think i saw like
a watchmojo video a long time ago which
is like the top 10 hardest xbox i was
like top 10 list of games i'm never
going to buy i'm one of them one of my
already owned like gears of war yeah it
was like good to get
uh like a hundred thousand online kills
yeah in the first game but like no one
was playing the first game after like
the third one came out how would that
even be possible i think how much you
don't have to do 1000 matches with your
mates
it's kills so you have to be averaging
like [ __ ] hundreds it's ridiculous
yeah
and gears of war is not an easy game to
get kills in yeah so it's it's very
difficult um i can find this i can find
it
all right i've i've got the list of all
of these some of these games are just
[ __ ] stupid i said i have 51 000
gamer score on xbox right
that's like what 50 yeah games 45 i've
every single cod game i have every
single achievement every single every
single halo game i have every single
achievement except for the newer ones
like uh halo wars 2 and
halo hello infinite i have all of them i
had i did all of the i don't know did
you ever do halo there was there was
those challenges where you had to like
do certain things without dying like the
skull ones did all of those i only
played halo 1 i've only played halo 1
and halo 3. i didn't play halo 2. i got
every single achievement in blue dragon
which i remember the dragon yeah the
jrpg yeah oh [ __ ]
um yeah i i remember you were talking
about this yeah yeah right yeah yeah
yeah i think um what's this one what's
most rare what's the rarest one head
trauma
uh
every type of melee weapon
that's so weird there's there's like
rare there's a lot in dead rising yeah
everything is a weapon i've killed yeah
okay some of these are like really low
uh some funny games i've done doritos
crash course too what were all of the
achievements on doritos crashed why
would you buy that game it was free no
the other question is why is there two
of them yeah it was really popular i've
got all the achievements on red dead i
think that wasn't too hard
um what else have i done what weird
games these so like would you basically
do nothing would you basically do
nothing until you 100 of these games
yeah i've played south park games i've
played the south park tower defense game
lost i have terminator salvation which i
think i got because that was easy but
then it turned out to be really [ __ ]
hard
um
what's weird what other games do i have
here god most of these are called an
assassin's creed
uh happy wars
i don't even know what that is i didn't
even do that one that must have been too
hard welcome wait hold on what was the
one after that guacamelee super turbo
champion dude that was a good game dude
that's
melee
and then other games i couldn't do them
all quite a lot of games actually a lot
of the gears of wars ones were just like
[ __ ] uh yeah
forza
destiny
[ __ ] dude i played some weird ass games
what's wrong with me well i think as a
kid you just played any game that you
could get your hands on yeah exactly
yeah
and now they're like
fifa of course of course
fitness
i i
i don't know why 509
i got all the achievements on halo wars
which one of them included getting to
the highest rank which takes like an
absurd amount of hours
she's a stupid amount